what's going on guys today we're going
to be breaking down these spoilers for
my academia chapter 324 which
immediately picks up from last week with
ochako begging civilians to let deku
back into ua this chapter features the
return of several minor characters in
both the forms of flashbacks and just in
the present day including this guy who
was killed during the war arc this
civilian who wished deku good luck in
like the very first episode and also
this lady who deku saved during the
villain hunt before we get into it don't
forget to subscribe with notifications
on for weekly spoiler videos like this
and let me know in the comments what do
you think of the chapter
okay so chapter 324 begins with a long
narration from uroraka saying that she
always loves seeing people happy and
when she saw heroes in action she paid
more attention to the people smiling in
the crowd than the heroes themselves the
civilians at ue seem to notice the mess
that deku has become commenting that he
looks weakened and all beaten up the
giant woman who i mentioned in the intro
says that midoriya saved her and then he
immediately left to continue fighting
despite that one of the civilians in the
crowd is especially skeptical and he
answered chaco if she is asking for the
civilians to also get covered in mud and
blood as well she replies by saying
that's not the case as they just need to
give deku some time to clean up all the
mud and you know this is referring to
geniuses plan as gina said in the last
chapter that they don't really want deku
to stay at your way permanently it's
just a temporary solution to you know
let him recover whilst he's there and
then immediately go back out into the
fight class 1a is shocked by what
they're seeing from achako where she's
kind of like commanding the stage and it
tells deku that right now she's fighting
to protect everyone's smiles including
his
deku then begins to cry and shout her
name and she continues her speech saying
that the heroes can't put people at ease
because they are also afraid and this
shows that they are just like everyone
else
in the narration she wonders once again
who will save the heroes when they're in
pain and i'm calling it now this is
officially this is officially a chakra's
catchphrase because uh this is about the
third or fourth time she's uh thought it
or said it out loud but it's a valid
statement to make though because heroes
are human beings regular civilians might
not perceive them as that and so in that
way people don't really feel sympathetic
to heroes they don't really feel like
heroes are able to show weakness and
things like that which is why certain
people in particular are not really
caring about the fact that deku needs to
come back to ua but rather they just
think heroes are almost like these
robots that need to go out and protect
them anyway the spoilers say that we see
several panels showing different
characters including izawa who is still
in the hospital there's then another
flashback over chaco with her parents
and they are watching the fight of a
hero named eel boy but ochaku is too
busy looking at other people's
expressions eel boy wins and smiles at
her which makes achako laugh and for
those who don't know eel boy is the guy
from the war arc who was stabbed in the
back of the head by twice and yeah his
quirk was quite interesting i actually
mentioned it in a video i did about all
the different quirks in the war arc
basically what it does it lets him shoot
out these different eels from i guess
each of his hands and they seem to have
some degree of like uh sentience like
almost like dark shadow they kind of
operate on their own to an extent twice
not only start this guy in the back of
the head but toga then pretended to be
this person and then went on to stab
other heroes as well
in the present day ochako asks the
civilians to lend their strength so that
they can get through these difficult
times so that they can all smile
together again at this moment she
remembers toga crying and hesitates for
a second but then asks the civilians to
stay by deku's side while he rests just
quickly on that point about together
crying so this actually happened back in
the war arc and i think there's two
reasons why chaka hesitates here number
one is that she's a person who always
likes to see other people happy as we
know and the fact that she as a hero
made someone else cry instead of making
them smile i think that's what gave a
reason to pause for a second now the
second reason is possibly due to what
they actually spoke about in their
conversation as during that talk togo
was basically trying to explain that she
can't suppress her nature and that when
she loves someone she has to drink their
blood and transform into them that's
just the way she is and ochako wasn't
sympathetic to that she was just like
you know if you're gonna commit these
crimes you need to pay the price and
that is what caused toka to cry because
otaku didn't understand her
back at uwa uraraka says that deku has
tried to carry the burden of his quirk
all by himself but that deep down he's
just a high school student who has a lot
to learn and yeah this is something that
i think we often forget deku is
literally like what 16 years old i think
they're all like 16 or 15 years old so
you know all the stuff they're going
through that's pretty heavy to be
dealing with at that age and it's
reasonable for the adults to let him
into your way let him rest for a bit and
then go back out to the battlefield like
it's not that much to ask deku then
falls to his knees as he remembers the
first time he met uraraka at the ua
entrance exam and we get a double page
spread of her yelling at everyone saying
to let him stay here at this hero
academy at the same time we get a rare
narration from adult deku and he says
that this is the story of how he became
the greatest hero and also something
else there's something else will be
revealed in a few seconds but first the
principal remembers his speech about the
lack of understanding and intolerance
and how sometimes it only takes one step
for people to understand each other the
giant woman and kota then dash towards
deku and we see a mini flashback of kota
choosing his red sneakers with mandalay
those sneakers were obviously inspired
by coach's admiration for midoriya and
we kind of already knew that already
just based on his reaction in season 4
but still it's cool to get this 110
confirmation that you know deku is
kota's hero the narration from adult
deku then continues and he says that
this is also the story of how they all
became the greatest hero which is a
massive twist on that line that we heard
in like i think the second episode but
now i mean this is basically implying
that they are all collectively going to
be the greatest it's not uh it's not a
one person thing and i think this is
actually a good thing because if we look
back at all my time as the number one
hero as soon as he retired everything
went to crap basically but i guess in
the future if the whole of class 1a and
i guess other heroes as well if they are
all collectively the greatest hero i
guess that means that if one person
retires or if one person
dies then it's not the end of the world
because they all have each other's backs
if you know what i mean the chapter then
ends with present day deku on the ground
crying as kota and the giant woman reach
out to him and uh yeah that's the end of
it so uh one thing that wasn't mentioned
in this specific league was that the guy
from the very first episode you know the
guy with like the weird uh star-shaped
things on his head so that was the guy
that wished deku good luck on his
journey to become a hero and this guy
was in the crowd at ua with an umbrella
just watching the whole thing unfold so
i'm kind of curious to know like does he
remember deku i mean i guess he does
look kind of different from when they
first interacted but on the other hand
it wasn't that long ago so maybe he
would remember this but yeah it's a
pretty cool cameo
anyway guys if you have any thoughts on
this chapter or any predictions for next
week then be sure to let me know in the
comments down below and also hit that
sub button if you haven't already until
the next one peace out